autre petite scène improvisée par
jacqueline maillan et jacques martin
voici le thème un jeune homme et une
jeune fille qui sait mais on était
séparés par leurs familles ils se
retrouvent vingt ans après et après la
petite clochette la france fatidique a
placé je ne voyais déjà en haut de la
fiche à vous mes enfants ah bon alors tu
rentres le premier ou non oui ça m'est
égal
voilà ton va taper les toiles d'accord
oui allez c'est parti
mais je ne connais pas mais si c'est oui
ma petite juliette
c'est vrai oui tu vois depuis les puits
ces témoins nicolas comment vas tu toi
hammouchi ça va bien que tu sais
pourquoi je n'ai pas voulu te t'épouser
parce que nos parents ne s'entendait pas
dit que c'était des gens charmants mais
qu'elles ont merdé possible chez toi
mais si tu n'es pas sans savoir j'étais
une fille très riche et qui faisait une
affaire d'argent
j'ai su ça je n'ai pas voulu céder à ce
chantage tuer sans inclure à
contrexéville cette année au je suis
imposé le marchand de venise enjeu
formidable courir et je vais te dire une
chose il faut des femmes n'a pas de
louche ou tu as été nommé ace qui toi ma
grande
je n'occupe a pas de la réflexion de
nuit ça manque d'eau qui les maisons
s'écroulent je participerai à la
renaissance de venise est encore salvia
heureuse ou très heureux et toi grand et
ben moi tu sais comme j'avais l'habitude
de monter chez toi par l'échelle après
je suis entré dans les pompiers j'ai
commencé quand j'étais très haut je
faisais non plus les balcons je faisais
les trente deuxièmes et quatrièmes puis
je suis tombé
et oui ans je ne peux plus mettre de
collants parce qu'on ne fait pas une
jambe et explique encore portal o et
quand bien mais pas montrer le dénigrer
la retraite et on verra ce moment c'est
de toujours
entre tous ses frères toujours aussi
envers de la sphère laurent et le faire
lance et il a pris la prime et horaires
les hommes avaient été déjà ma chérie fm
km à la hausse et a grandi et comme moi
j'ai tu sais j'ai l'esprit que ça me tue
c'est ô combien et pour cause je l'aide
d'un petit peu c'est pour ça que je
vienne en robe de chambre parce que j'ai
beaucoup de travail sont beaucoup de
monde à l'église je croyais qu'ils
auraient plutôt ouvert une pharmacie non
non je pense qu'il a il s'est bien
trompé sur l'a12 à mérida elle sera le
maître tu secoues été giflée puis quand
j'ai vu que ça remue et plus qui te dis
que je te l'avais dit à l'époque
oui oui juliette je t'aimais bien à peu
près dans la foule oui je suis désolé
mais sous l'édredon
j'aimais ça
à l'élaboration pour donner la saison
qui m'a donné le goût de l'histoire je
traversé
quelques tragédies aussi et je suis
tombé sur et sexuellement avec le
marchand de venise tu t'entends bien
c'est très implanté dans un conte
forcément je me voyais déjà en haut de
la fiche puisque il est normal que je
fais mais n'aurait copiner avec othello
étant donné que je suis à venise